[Music]
Dave I work in a job that qualifies me
to have my student loans forgiven in ten
years if I work here I pay minimum
payments on the student loans and
because I work at this government
service job or this community service
job my student loans will be forgiven
after 10 years the answer to that is
always don't do it get your loans paid
off as quick as you can for God's sakes
don't stay in debt for 10 years and have
you heard that the government is
questioning whether or not they're
actually going to do this or not
so this comes from MarketWatch CBS the
government loan forgiveness program has
rejected 99% of borrowers so far only 96
people are included in the first cohort
of borrowers of the public service loan
forgiveness program 96 people in the
United States so far have had their
loans forgiven the public service loan
forgiveness program 96 so far roughly
99% of processed applications for
forgiveness under a government program
aimed at helping public servants manage
their federal student loan debt had
their applications rejected as of June
30th this year about 28,000 borrowers
submitted 33 thousand three hundred
applications to have their loans
discharged under the public service loan
forgiveness program an initiative
launched in 2007 that allows borrowers
who work in certain types of public
service to have their federal student
loans wiped away after 10 years of
payments what I was just talking about
of the roughly 29,000 applications
process so far 96 I've had five point
five two million in debt discharged
under the program according to a
government report released Wednesday
experts expect the number of approved
applications to rise in the coming years
when the program launched in 2007 there
was little publicity or clarity around
it
many who watched the public service loan
forgiveness program closely have been
concerned for years that would be me
among them that it's complicated mix of
requirements would make it difficult for
borrowers to access there's also likely
a large cohort of borrowers who believed
they'd be able to claim forgiveness
under the program and perhaps organize
their careers in the financial lives
around it but weren't aware or were
confused by its many requirements
rendering them in eligible thirty three
thousand three hundred applications
ninety-six have been approved if you're
waiting on the government to fix your
life you're screwed get your student
loans paid off as soon as possible to
start with let's just assume that you
were one of the ninety-six
you've still waited 10 freaking years to
start your life you waited 10 years to
start your financial life that's asinine
it's ridiculous we have people on here
every single day doing debt free screams
that have paid off fifty thousand a
hundred thousand a hundred and fifty
thousand and student loan debt and
they've done it in one two three years
not ten I got it out of their life they
were done with it
they weren't waiting on the welfare to
fix their life when you wait on welfare
to fix your life you get screwed you get
screwed and that's what's happened so I
mean seriously some of you've been you
know jerking around with this you've
been thinking I'm gonna I'm gonna win
this I'm gonna play the government game
I'm gonna dumb my life down to the bell
curve and I'm gonna wait 10 freaking
years for them to forgive a portion of
my debt the portion that I have not read
reduced oh I forgot I didn't check into
it I don't meet the requirements
I'm ineligible thirty-three thousand
three hundred people made apple error
thirty-three thousand three hundred
applications by twenty eight thousand
people ninety six were approved Houston
there's a problem I mean really you've
got to be kidding me
listen that almost sounds like the odds
of winning the lotto it's like yeah I
bet you buy lotto tickets too don't you
the government's going to pay off my
student loan debt and I'm gonna win the
lotto two statements made by fools who
thought they were going to build wealth
nope you're not gonna build wealth that
way you're gonna build wealth when you
take control and don't wait on dumb luck
and government programs to fix your life
how many people have you ever met in
your life now I haven't met thousands
and thousands of millionaires
how many millionaires do you think I met
this Dave you know government program
made me rich a government program
substantially contributed to the fact
that I'm a millionaire you know I have a
ten thousand millionaires that we serve
eight how many of them said that none
not one you never said they won the
lotto
none not one so here's the thing you
know in other words are you going to
believe in unicorns are you going to
believe in mythology are you wait and
when you say the government is going to
fix my life that is the definition of
mythology the government is actually
going to help me generally speaking is
mythology now I'm not angry at the
government I'm just angry that the
government has convinced a bunch of you
that they are the source of hope I
believe in you
I don't believe in them
I don't trust them I don't think there's
malice involved I don't think they're a
bunch of crooks I don't think it's a
conspiracy theory I think they are it is
the largest case of incompetence in
human history they meant well but they
absolutely do not know how to do well
they want to help people but they
absolutely cannot seem to get out of
their own freakin way to get there and
this is proof of it yet again 28,000
people made thirty three thousand three
hundred applications to have their
student loans forgiven under the public
service loan forgiveness program ninety
six were approved all else were rendered
in eligible because they did not meet
their requirements which means you
didn't know what the requirements were
you didn't bother to look at them they
didn't bother to tell you they weren't
even sure they make crap up as they go
along and they changed things if you're
waiting on them to get you out of
student loan debt you're you're dumber
than a rock you really are you're asking
well you're just asking for a mess
because you believe the mythology when
someone said hi I'm from the government
and I'm here to help when you hear that
you should run
run this is the Dave Ramsey show